Speaker 1: I want to follow up on my
coverage from earlier this week about
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones and
what has taken place over the last
four or five days with Alex Jones is really
remarkable, and it informs a number of different
aspects of these coalitions that have been built
over the last four years and their fragility,
quite frankly. Conspiracy theorist Alex Jones
was a big Trump supporter for a long time.
He's also a big, anti-vax guy spreading unhinged,
debunked vaccine propaganda regularly for the last
year, year and a half. Donald Trump recently made
two very mild pro-vaccine comments, while he said,
I still oppose mandates and everybody has to have
freedom. Donald Trump did say on stage with Bill
O'Reilly, I got the booster. The vaccines are
good and the vaccines work. And then Donald Trump
said to Candace Owens during an interview, The
people dying overwhelmingly are the unvaccinated
and the right. The anti-vax rate has gone
crazy. Some of them now see Trump as a traitor.
One of those people is conspiracy theorist Alex
Jones. So we're going to look at a couple of clips
and pay attention to the degree of fragility for
these coalitions. That immediately is made evident
by Trump saying something so mild and milquetoast
about vaccines. Here is the first clip this one's
from the weekend. We already played this one
earlier in the week, but just just for context,
Speaker 3: is an emergency Christmas Day warning
to President Trump. You were either completely
ignorant about the so-called vaccine gene therapy
that you helped ram through with Operation Warp
Speed, or you're one of the most evil men who has
ever lived to push this toxic poison on the public
and to attack your constituents.
Speaker 1: Now, just to be. I've been told it's
really important that I that I do this so that our
content doesn't get blocked. The vaccines are not
gene therapies and they are not poison.
Speaker 3: They simply try to save their
lives and the lives of others. We're about
to lay out the basic, incontrovertible facts
that what you told Candace Owens just a few
days ago is nothing but a raft of dirty lies.
Speaker 1: That is untrue. What Donald Trump said
to Candace Owens actually is true. But let's look
at some other examples of this. Here is Alex Jones
losing his mind on Donald Trump for what he calls
a satanic alien attack, a satanic alien attack in
Speaker 3: children with deadly poison everywhere
that they know erases their immune system. And
Trump is running around in his stupid red dye,
playing the part of The Apprentice CEO.
Speaker 1: It is important to know that the
vaccine does not a race your immune system,
Speaker 3: telling everybody, Oh,
you're playing into their
hands, not taking their shot.
No, Trump, you are playing into their hands
and destroying yourself and signing yourself
on to the new world order.
Speaker 1: The vaccines
are not part of a new world order conspiracy
Speaker 3: idiot Bill O'Reilly. What a pervert.
Does he know how to pick women up?
Speaker 1: Bill O'Reilly may be
a pervert that actually may be accurate.
Speaker 3: It's all just an incredible joke.
See, I just can't get mad
on air anymore. You know,
there's a Greg Reese report is a rigorous
report. They just filed it's so important,
and so let's just air that. And I may
just go to rebroadcast. I'm not trying
to be dramatic here. I just, I know just never
come back. You know, I mean, seriously, just
let everybody have what you want. Let Shepard
Pelosi rob you. Let a molest your children.
Let them take your 14 year olds away.
Speaker 1: And there is no evidence
that Nancy Pelosi or Adam Schiff have
ever or planned to molest any children
Speaker 3: their genitals off. You love it.
Everybody's too busy with their own life and
their own thing and their own this and their
own candy ass B.S. to wake up out of the coma.
But there is a satanic and alien
attack going on on this planet.
Speaker 1: Vaccines are not a satanic
offworld alien attack. OK, so understand
how fragile these alliances are. These people have
principles that they abandon as soon as reality
conflicts with the principles. These people form
coalitions that are so fragile that as soon as
there is any difference of opinion, you have Alex
Jones seemingly having a psychotic break. Look at
this next clip. I mean, look at what is taking
place here because Trump said, Hey, the vaccines
are pretty good at protecting people from dying,
Speaker 3: persecuted for supporting Trump. It
makes it ten times worse because I know Podesta's.
If you want to know Hillary's evil and Obama is
evil and I know she's evil and I know Bill Gates
is evil and I know they're all evil. But Trump
did a lot of good and I believed in him. And so
the fact that he's done this makes it personal.
It makes it hurt persecuted for supporting Trump.
Speaker 1: So look at the look at the triggering.
Alex Jones, who, as he says
was a major Trump supporter,
cannot handle, cannot handle Trump's mild
support for vaccines. Let's look at just
a couple more of these or take credit for.
Speaker 3: It's a great what we've done is
this ozone in sign on to it. Take credit for it.
Take this shine on. Believe it. I mean, hell,
we will find Bill Gates and Fauci and Biden in the
new world order. Psaki and and the Day Squibb and
Peter Daszak. And now we got Trump on their team.
Speaker 1: So Trump now officially persona non
grata. According to Alex Jones, he was just
one last thing. There's this sort of pseudo.
This is pro-Trump activist Allison Steinberg,
who was invited also onto Infowars.
She also now has turned on Trump. Check this out.
Speaker 2: A lot of you are probably going to say,
Oh, well, I don't care what he does because
this is about medical freedom as long as we
have the choice. He's not even giving you the
choice. If you go to his hotel in New York,
you have to show proof of papers.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, the proof of papers,
by the way, is proof of vaccination. What
I understand that nobody's forcing you to
go to Trump's hotel. You have total choice.
There's no obligation to go to Trump's hotel.
Speaker 2: How can you continue to
blindly defend this man? I don't get it.
Make it make sense, please. Trump do some
great things while in office. Absolutely.
Was I a supporter? I was a huge one. But there
is no denying that what he is doing is evil.
Speaker 1: So there it is, just incredibly
fragile alliances in the world of Trump ism and
the the the reality that we have to understand
is that these people, when you don't really have
principles to begin with, and that's one of
the hallmarks of the Trump movement, which is.
Part of why he won is he activated people who
had no idea about the political world history,
what how politics works. Their first involvement
in politics was, Oh, I kind of like the stuff,
Trump said. I'm going to vote for him. And so when
you don't really bring any principles in by which
you evaluate the man that you end up idolizing
almost like a deity, you don't even really have a
political ideology against which to evaluate their
future actions. And that's why you're seeing these
very people immediately turn on Donald Trump. It's
fascinating to see. And Alex Jones really, really
seems to be struggling there. We're going to
take a quick break and be back right after this.